اعذار النظام الايراني وامتصاص اخطائه
تحولت لها دول الغرب فهناك يرمي انتهاكاته
بمجالاتها المتعدده ليزعم وقوف من يصفهم
بالاعداء خلف كل ما يجري في بلاده
فصول قمع الاحتجاجات لم تنتهي بعد ليتسرب
عبرها غاز تسبب بتسمم طالبات في المدارس
هذه ايضا تهمه الصقها بطريقه ما الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي بالغرب الذي يسعى
وفق تعبيره لاشاعه التوتر والذعر بين
الطلاب واولياء امورهم واثاره الاضطرابات
في ايران
معاناه الفتيات الايرانيات وسلبهن حق
التعليم بات موضع قلق دول غربيه عده بينها
الولايات المتحده والمانيا فهجمات السم
الخفيف فسرها السياسيون على انها استهداف
من قبل الجماعات المتشدده المعارضه لتعليم
الفتيات
يجب ان تتمكن الفتيات من الذهاب الى
المدرسه بلا خوف هذا حقهن الانساني ببساطه
يجب التحقيق بشكل كامل في كل الحالات
حالات تسمم متوسط لمئات الفتيات اعلنت
عنها وزاره الصحه الايرانيه خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وبين السوق الاتهامات
والقاء اللوم وجه رئيس وزراء الداخليه
والامن بمتابعه قضايا التسمم في المدارس
فيما كلف رئيس مجلس الشورى محمد باقر
قليباث اربعه لجان برلمانيه بالتحقيق
واكتشاف اسباب الحوادث وقد تم القاء القبض
على ثلاثه اشخاص اشتبه بتورطهم في القضيه
لكن الاجهزه الامنيه نفت اكتشافها لماده
سامه قد تكون السبب في تسمم الطلبه